well unfortunately guys I cannot bring
you a review of the 3d screening of Thor
the dark world because of the
projectionists working at my screening
suck at their jobs whatever they were
doing that could not get the 3d to work
so we watched it in 2d actually I didn't
mind that at all but where the dark
world is directed by Alan Taylor not
Kenneth Branagh which means no Dutch
angles don't get me wrong I enjoyed the
first floor but every single shot going
like this got a little knowing after a
while so basically this evil dark elf
Malekith wants to be in control of this
ether it's this all-powerful substance
that can control and destroy and
recreate and he wants to be the guy who
harnesses that for is the one guy
obviously who wants to stop that from
happening so he teams up with Loki his
brother to try to go against him to save
the universe no I enjoyed the first Thor
movie didn't love it though so my one
thing going into this movie I was
thinking if I enjoy it more than Thor I
will be happy and I left happy Thor the
dark world is a movie that I had a lot
of fun with I thought there was a lot of
things that were improved over the first
one for one I thought it was a much
better looking movie I thought Alan
Taylor added a great sense of visuals to
this movie and I'm not just talking
about a lot of cool special effects some
of the backgrounds and scenery looked
fantastic and there were some really
great scenic shots in this movie there's
some times where people zap from
different locations really fast and
you're just blown away by how cool the
world looks and that was really my thing
about the first Thor that kind of got on
my nerves a little bit was the fact that
I loved all the Asgard stuff and the
Bifrost stuff that just felt so much
like Thor to me but all the earth scenes
felt kind of uninteresting and except
for some of the humor that was created
whenever Thor had to interact with
humans for the most part of the earth
stuff just felt like it wasn't as
interesting this movie there's a lot
more of Thor kicking ass in Asgard and
all over the place and that's something
I really enjoyed about this movie
because you got to see Thor in action it
felt more freeing than the first movie
which felt more confined because he
didn't have his powers which is a cool
way to get you to relate more to Thor
but I wanted to see more of Thor you
his Thor like powers and Thor the dark
world gave that to me I think they
realized at this point that Loki is
awesome and that he adds so much to
these movies The Avengers movie in the
first Thor movie he just is a character
that is so fun and so entertaining but
his interplay with Thor that too was
something that I really thought was
strong about this movie worth those two
actors chemistry with one another their
dialogue and just seeing them on the
screen trying to find a way to co-exist
as they try to help each other
throughout this problem that was
definitely I thought the strongest point
of this movie and while it is there and
those characters interact with each
other and it's a lot of fun when it's
there there wasn't enough of that I
wanted more Chris Hemsworth his greatest
Thor at this point I can't really see
anyone else playing him I think he's
terrific as the character and that's
something that I got to give props to
all the filmmakers involved with this
film and the first one is the fact that
Thor is probably the most difficult of
all of the Avengers to tell a cohesive
and grounded story because he's so out
there literally and figuratively his
character is so different and very
difficult to relate to and they really
do a good job of grounding him and
making you be able to relate to that
character in his world Idris Elba is so
cool in this movie too his character is
even more badass than he was in the
first film Anthony Hopkins is great as
Odin Rene Russo has her moments in this
movie too she isn't just kind of wander
around like she did in the first one
checks it gets to kick some butt in this
movie which is pretty cool Natalie
Portman is that is one attractive woman
that really is a good-looking woman that
is a good-looking woman okay done cuz
that's not really a critique on the film
that's just my personal my personal
thoughts but her character is fun too in
this movie but there's an aspect of the
whole human Thor thing that still
doesn't quite work in this movie there
was a lot of comic relief with the
character of Darcy played by kat
dennings except i didn't really find her
presence very comical or relieving she
was kind of annoying a gun on my nerves
at times also there's this whole romance
thing kind of brewing with a new intern
that works for them that just felt
completely unnecessary didn't need to be
there at all like totally could deleted
that character didn't like that
character there are certain characters
that in my opinion aren't very funny but
they're trying to be already mentioned
that but there was still a good sense of
humor in this movie
they had more scenes where Thor was
interacting with the human world which
were just hilarious in the first film
and even more funny in this one because
he just doesn't fit in and the film
really understands that because as a
character for us to be able to relate to
him they have to have those moments
where he has to try to be a normal
person and it just doesn't work because
he's four and so it's funny and it makes
us be able to relate to that character
more and they did a good job with that
in this movie also stellan skarsgrd was
pretty hilarious in this movie too he
has some great moments plusses of this
movie are the action scenes are very
well filmed there are a lot of fun there
is a good amount of them and that's
really cool to see because that was
lacking in the first Thor movie there
wasn't enough of Thor out there doing
his Thor like duties and we get to see
that in this movie which is awesome the
interplay between him and Loki is
fantastic I just wish there was more of
it
Tom Hiddleston excellent as Loki now I
haven't mentioned my biggest problem
with this movie and it is by far the
villain Malekith completely
uninteresting villain he came off as a
cheesy Star Trek original series episode
villain like he just wants to be in
control of this ether and he walks
around going bust up the entire first
half of the movie all of his stuff is in
subtitles which makes sense he's with
his native people he will speak in his
native tongue but you just you can't
relate to him as a villain and he comes
off so science fictiony cheesy and very
Star Trek II which doesn't mesh with the
Thor world in my opinion so as a villain
I was very disappointed in him I just
wish that that villain was more imposing
physically and more imposing as a threat
he just didn't feel like he was a threat
mentally or physically to Thor Thor just
seemed better at everything than he was
and he just wanted to have this stuff
and you're coming off of a villain as
awesome as Loki is this is just like a
major step down in the villainy area the
coolest villain I thought in this movie
was actually a secondary villain this
guy cursed this big gigantic guy who
could just take on anything and walk
through walls and just take apart
anything that I thought was way better
than anything the actual villain does in
the whole movie nevertheless I did have
a good time with Thor the dark world
I enjoyed it more than the first one I
thought that it improved a lot of the
things that I thought were wrong with
the first one I'm gonna give Thor the
dark world
a b-plus I do like it more than the
first one I think that's a lot of fun as
a movie it's not without its flaws but I
still had a good time at the movies
so guys when you see the movie let me
know what you thought of below thanks as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]